For years you've been avoiding earth
i have called for your help plenty of
other times and you've been pretty content
to let those calls go straight to voicemail
yeah well this is different
how much you know about your security detail
what do you mean how much do i know about him
fury we're gonna be very careful now
you're in no shape for this
fight that lies before us
this is just the beginning this is my war alone
and i'm the last person standing between them
and what they really want
and what is that
Welcome back everyone this will be my full
marvel secret invasion trailer video there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here for what's going
on in the mcu during this part of the timeline
obviously everybody wondering what nick fury has
been up to while he's been on his space station
this whole time because so much has been happening
the real version of maria hill even makes a joke
about that in the trailer i've been calling you
and basically he hasn't been picking up her phone
calls so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos of course i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes when it premieres next year and
it will be starting next year to be like one of
the bigger series along with loki's season two
the big thing that's happening in this is
they're doing a version of secret invasion
obviously everybody remembers that arc from the
comics is a little bit different from the comics
is that they're playing at more of the political
thriller aspect where a sect of religious zealot
skrulls are trying to take over the earth so it
is the skrulls it's not like a version of kree
pretending to be skrulls but there might be some
kree stuff going up i thought kree having sleeper
cells was top secret information they're just
playing up the skrulls arc because so many people
are shape-shifting like you see taylo's part of
the good skrulls working with nick fury going up
against ben kingsley adeer's character one of the
evil skrulls in a bunch of the other ones that are
with him shape-shift into his form there are a lot
of familiar faces obviously there will be a lot of
connections to the avengers movies avengers 5 kang
dynasty avengers 6 secret wars captain america 4
even the thunderbolts movie probably what's
happening in the marvels movie just because
of the skrulls and nick fury connection they might
not be doing more than jokes about avengers being
skrulls because in the comics the whole idea was
who do you trust in like all the skrulls were
impersonating pretty much every major character
in marvel comics like all the avengers x-men
everybody the tone of this seems a little bit more
serious a little bit darker so they might have
references to that but i'm not expecting to see
like every single avenger as a skrull the other
big thing during this trailer to let you know
that it is the real nick fury is he looks a little
bit older and he's not wearing the eye patch it
sounds like a lot of the series takes place all
over europe like a lot of it takes place in the
uk but some of it takes place in russia i don't
know if they've changed that because of what's
happened in real life recently there were some
re-shoots that they reported that they tweaked a
couple things but at the beginning of the trailer
you see nick fury come to earth again finally it
seems like this is the first time he's been on
planet in a while in one of the skrulls spaceships
that has been on the space station this whole time
like the whole joke here in the trailer with maria
hill's character is that he's finally returned
like he's finally answering her phone calls this
time is different in the hype of the separate sect
of skrulls obviously amelia clarke's character
being part of the good skrulls being this really
big character lots of rumors about her playing a
version of the skrull empress or someone tied to
the throne of the skrulls. The skrull empress was
just integral in the plot of the original secret
invasion but the way they played the character in
the comic book arc she was a little bit more evil
i think the twist in this series is that she's
actually trying to work with them but she's also
tied to this evil sect of skrulls too so she's
kind of caught in between the different groups of
skrulls the other big cameo scene during this is
war machine and it does seem like it's meant to be
the real version of war machine although they will
also probably have jokes about that too like is
this the real war machine during this scene or is
it one of the skrulls pretending to be war machine
they were also hyping up armor wars which is going
to be big roadie iron man series happening in the
next couple of years but they didn't announce an
official release date i believe that's going to be
during 2024. nick fury explains to him this whole
plot with the evil skrulls pretending to be his
security detail like he doesn't completely know
what's going on next big cameo scene is everett
ross obviously we just saw him during the black
panther wakanda forever trailer my understanding
is that this is meant to take place after black
panther wakanda forever so he'll probably come
into this series referencing some of the things
that have happened before but the way that they've
tried to demarcate the different series in
the movies i think you'll be able to watch
this without having seen black panther wakanda
forever but pretty much everybody on the planet is
probably going to see that movie so i really don't
think it's going to be a big deal in that case
i'm not totally sure who olivia coleman is playing
she might be part of the good skrulls or she could
be a regular human all these seem like they're
skrull bodies and they might be part of this sect
that they're investigating and during the scene
of talos versus the evil skrull ben kingsley adir
there's meant to be this clever easter egg in the
background you probably noticed it says the faces
of freedom as all the other skrulls faces change
to his face and i think the thing these evil
skrulls want because tales are saying we have to
be really careful here and if gary says that he's
the only person that stands between them and what
they want it's probably just meant to be the earth
there's all the jokes between the marvel movies
with the earth ending catastrophes that they
have in every single movie like here we go again
another earth-ending catastrophe is it going to
be another celestial trying to burst out of the
planet is it going to be somebody trying to take
over the planet is it another thanos coming along
trying to steal something from earth the canonical
reason in the mcu why the earth is such a locus of
trouble why people want earth so badly is because
it's a nexus point of a bunch of magical ley lines
a bunch of power flowing through it it's also the
planet that king was born on so it has to survive
it has to be important for him to become who he's
supposed to be in every reality it's just because
of the multiverse aspect of kang's character in
general when you're talking about his locus of
power being on earth it's not just the 616 earth
it's like every single version of earth that's out
there and when you're talking about the skrulls
like in a larger political sense in the galaxy
it's a very strategic position in the galaxy
and a lot of what's happening here probably ties
in with the kree skrull war that's been going on
for hundreds and hundreds of years that's kind of
what happened in the comics is the decree and the
skrulls both separately wanted the earth because
it was a very strategic position in the war
between their cultures but the difference in this
series is that you have two different factions
of skrulls like you have the good skrulls that
nick fury has been working with this whole time
and you have an evil religious zealot group of
skrulls that want to take over their culture
and take their race in a way more hardcore
direction you can let me know in the comments what
you think this special thing is in the case it's
a very pulp fiction seven type of reference like
what's in the box like what's that gold shining
like coming out and you have nick fury because sam
jackson was also in pulp fiction this particular
scene with them opening up this mystery box with
something inside might be a misdirect but i think
in the grander sense they just want to take over
earth in general and replace all of earth's
leaders with skrulls this room here that amelia
clark's character walks into seems like it's in
russia just based on the language somebody can
correct me in the comics if that's not totally
accurate but i believe what's happening here is
that the evil skrulls are building something that
will help them take over the planet you also have
to remember that nick fury's character has had the
space station in orbit they've been cloaked this
whole time which is why you haven't seen a whole
lot of them outside of post-credit scenes and
little winks and easter eggs and i believe during
this series they'll explain why nick fury has been
so off the radar this whole time why he didn't
get involved why he didn't try to help spider-man
out during the events of spider-man no way home
leading to the whole doctor strange plot then
messing the spell up and it'll have something to
do with this big skrull takeover that's been going
on in the background but hopefully that'll explain
the political thriller element of this series as
opposed to comic book secret invasion which was
more like a big action adventure series with the
entire mcu roster i believe these episodes are
supposed to be released before loki season 2
sometime in the spring so we'll probably
get some sort of footage or trailer either
before the end of the year or early next
year everyone post all your reactions in
the comments below and let me know what your
theories are about amelia clark's character
these evil skrulls and what nick fury has been
doing this whole time one of the other biggest
surprises during this big marvel disney plus
presentation was them actually doing a daredevil
born again panel where they talked a little
bit about the series with vincent d'annaprio's
kingpin making a bunch of jokes with charlie
cox about how it was his series even though
daredevil is in the title of the series aren't
you supposed to talk about my show wait your show
i think it'd be my show
like your show are you talking about my show they
haven't started filming it yet so obviously they
didn't have footage to show off for it but they
did remind everyone the kingpin will show up in
the echo series and will have a bandage over his
eye that she shot which is right out of the comics
daredevil is getting ready to cameo in the
she-hulk episodes real soon so i'll talk more
about daredevil born again when he comes around
for that i think you're in a unique position to
do some real good jen walters can use the law to
help people when society fails and she-hulk can
help people when the law fails this guy's really
kind of doing it for me marvel also released a
bunch more information about thunderbolts captain
america 4 they released a new trailer for werewolf
by night which is starting in october it's going
to be like a one-off special i'll do videos for
all that stuff as quickly as possible so be
sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that everyone click here for my
brand new mandalorian season 3 trailer video
and clicking for all my other marvel trailer
videos i'll update the link as soon as i post
those thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!